vous connaissez houba houba ah non
jamais vous connaissez personne de
l'équipe non non vous n'avez vous avez
envie de les connaître moi il est sympa
même de leur mode alors vous ne
connaissiez pas j'avais déjà vu j'ai vu
le l'épreuve du hac angers batirov hier
c'est pas possible a dit boyle parce
qu'on ne l'a pas fait aujourd'hui
l'épreuve a gelé
[Applaudissements]
tél
et en plus tous les deux on a on a un
point commun c'est à dire vous avez de
nombreux clashs et moi aussi
c'est vrai qu'on déclare jean qu'on
mange quoi wei allemagne il ya dix ans
joey starr au nom commun voilà on a
également baissé tout a parfois moi j'ai
hélène rollès élèves et collègues
d'hélène et les garçons scène d'hélène
et les garçons s'est clashé avec moi
diouf voulais me pète avec alain delon
eux vous voulez y pala de long non
moyens et arthur aussi qu'ils se cachent
beaucoup avec moi voilà donc le vous
l'avez pas aussi me ramène pas des
ennemis qu'il en voulait il ya la
fouille il ya rohff yaccarini siaap en
classe avec la foule ça c'est fini non
non je suis pas caché que la fouine et
j'aime bien il va nous voir c'est
parfois ça va mieux être la fouine ou
pas ça va aller mieux je sais pas ce qui
devient non mais mais monsieur booba
mois
[Applaudissements]
mais on va de l'émission le gars c'est
le conseil avant garde
écoutez monsieur ben moubamba contre
mathieu delormeau booba voici ton poids
matthieu delormeau attention vous devez
rester quoi ton record bras tendu comme
ça encore il s'appelle rohff bras tendus
[Applaudissements]
et
et ouais bon attention et va calmer
quand même merci d'avoir été avec nous
booba j'espère que vous allez gagner
sinon moi c'est casser la tête pendant
six ans mais john mendel perdre et il
perdra jamais attention à ce qu'on
pouvait pour s'entraîner parce que vous
pouvez vous sent très souple et merci
aux basques au point bien là près de lui
attention c'est parti
bras tendus a donné partie 3-2 atop lolo
wattrelos euro le bras au le bras lourds
un peu c'est long ça va ou pas tu me dis
sinon tu ressens presque aux autres et
juste après je crois qu'un film c'est
quoi le film en régie après prochain war
iii ça va faire un carton
mais pas vu non eh ben vous reste ici on
pas pour le diffuser on va voir qui
gagnent entre booba et matthieu
delormeau bien sûr de moi s'offrir
observer la chose je suis triste et de
lanvaux n'est pas bien les gars son
mental
[Applaudissements]
voir